hey sal tell everyone your story about
the afterlife and
uh and dimes tell the story no no dimes
well if you believe in the afterlife
know that uh dimes can be a sign
from uh people who have passed on as a
sign that they're with you
go ahead
okay here's a go if you're thinking of a
loved one who passed away and you're and
you're talking to them and you want to
communicate with them
and you happen to see a dime that dime
could be a sign from that loved one
saying that they here
or it could just be a lost dime it could
be a lost time
so how does that how does that help you
if you see the dime you don't know if
it's
random or if it's a loved one sending
down a dime
for me i know it's someone sending down
a dime other people might dismiss it but
i
i know i make the connections sal there
was a story where you saw a dime and it
was a sign from your friend's dead wife
right yeah how do you know
so we were at a birthday party for uh
a friend and i went to park my car
and it was also her brother-in-law's
birthday it was a double birthday party
her
her best friend and her brother-in-law
when i parked my car her brother-in-law
approached me
i opened the trunk of my car and we both
stopped at a dime between our feet
so we were thinking of her that day
it was a celebration for her family and
friends
and it was her way of saying hey i'm
here at this birthday party with you
that's how the timing of that the
synchronicity of that
it was amazing it's fair to say that sal
has the iq of a dime
south tell me how it works in heaven do
they give you a roll of dimes
or are there unlimited dimes that they
send out how does it work
how does god handle that i see i don't
know i don't have the answer to that
howard but i think
in the afterlife there's no time and
space in the afterlife and they have the
ability to go back into time
and place things in certain areas for
you
because they know you're going to reach
out to them well let me ask you this
the other day i was taking a walk and i
saw a group of pennies
on the ground and right they seemed to
spell something out and it said
sal is stupid now i saw that you got a
sign
i got a sign i think
uh oh i just got a sign a dime fell out
of my ass i don't know